不知道在你的童年中有没有一个陪伴了你很久的玩具，你是否也曾经幻想过他会趁你不注意的时候活过来呢？
今天我们继续以编剧视角拉片皮克斯3D动画长片的开衫制作玩具总动员，现在让我们一起来走进玩具的世界吧。看完相信你也能复刻出这样优秀的故事。
第26趴第58分钟。
我们说。
叫最后一颗爆炸啊，最后一个爆炸，两个人准备一起合作逃出束缚，但是已经太晚了啊，太晚了，对面搬家已经开始了，时间锁就到了啊，几个时间锁就到了。
也就是说几个时间锁同时引爆，最后一秒爆炸嘛，记不记得最后一秒爆炸这个理论？
然后2我们说他们为解决危机发起的第一次行动，必然一失败啊，我要再次失败，再次转折嘛。好吧，所以说第27趴也就是从第59分钟，巴斯又被反派带走了啊，准备用窜天猴炸了他。
然后这时候胡弟带领重组玩具们展开了营救行动啊，这些重组玩境苦勤酒矣，对吧？受压迫酒矣，然后大家合作引开恶犬，逃出房间，然后在同一个大厂里面啊，胡弟领导着大家啊，胡弟才再回重新回到领袖地位，领导着这些新的朋友，新的伙伴啊。
呃，战胜了反医，但战胜反医是用什么魔法战胜弄生的呢？是用他们暴露了自己会说话这个魔法啊，暴露的所有的玩具都是有生命。这个魔法这是他们的大招嘛，他们之前一直不敢在人类面前暴露。虽然没有说暴露了会怎么样。你看啊这个故事的世界观规则实际上也交代的不算那么清楚。
同学们在这里记一笔啊，玩具它只讲了玩具的存在是让小主人开心这么一个规则，但是没有去严格的讲暴露了会怎样什么什么什么这些事情。
懂吗？
所以在这里这场如果前面有规则，那么这场暴露劲儿可以更大一点。但是呢在这里啊在这里。
主动暴露自己的秘密，把那个反译给战胜了啊，把那个反译吓成吓傻了，对吧？玩具都活了，把那个反译吓傻。
但是在这里先打个括号。
主角团解决这么大的危机，没有用。
自己的伙伴记不记得第二场铺垫伙伴的技能缺陷性格，那不白铺垫了吗？对不对？但是在这场你没办法呀，你在人家家里啊，在人家地盘对吧？而且这些重组玩具也是刚认识的，所以用用的是重组玩具，因为带领伙伴完成任务是非常重要，非常有仪式感的戏。
因为胡底最在意的是什么？胡底最在意的是自己的领袖地位，所以带领伙伴完成任务是肯定这场戏是必然要有的。但是在这里竟然没有带自己的伙伴，哎呀，那就不行，所以在第28，也就是65分钟，他们解去解第二个扣，我们说第一个危机解决了。
我们再去解决第二个危机，也就是小主人搬家的车开走了这件事情。然后胡迪和巴斯去扒着扒着垃圾车追击，这里出现了一个鸣场面，记不记得很多人车上有这个玩意儿啊，同学们很多人车上有这个巴斯在这里啊舍身救助胡底，舍身救胡迪。因为那个恶犬来了啊，巴斯在这里救了一下胡底。
呃，忽垫了一下巴斯即将成为英雄。在这里大家知道为什么开始巴斯要救胡弟了，之前都是胡迪救巴斯，这里为什么巴斯救胡弟了，因为巴斯要开始成为英雄了啊，胡迪呢这时候再去叫自己的伙伴啊，自己的伙伴马上要派上用场了，因为得把自己伙伴唤醒，然后用自己的伙伴，解决最后的大危机，因为解决大危机必须是自己的伙伴。因为胡迪原本是个领袖，他被推翻了，他要回到自己的位置，他要夺回大家的爱。
然后呢，刚才巴斯不是舍身救胡地吗？这这里胡地在带着伙伴们把巴斯光年救回来。
把8斯关节救回来，然后回到第29拍，也就是第669分钟。
库迪和巴斯京诚合作啊，京城合作啊，那个获得了新的解决方案，也就是点燃火箭再次飞翔啊，再次飞翔。当然了，这里也是出现了好几次意外情况啊，先是火柴被吹灭，又是飞到天上飞过头，懂吗？各种意外啊，那个记不记得我在让你们写高潮戏的时候，有个口诀叫再次意外。
他这里再次意外两回啊再次意外两回。
写高潮戏的时候，我教你们需要再次意外，记不记得这个口诀，他这里意外两回，对吧？
但是也实现了巴斯飞翔的第三个第三场戏，记一下这里是巴斯第三次飞场飞翔，然后实现了巴斯的大成长啊，大成长。巴斯终于成为了英雄，两个人回到了小主人的身边，30拍，也就是第72分钟。
在新家里。
圣诞节又拆礼物了，又到了新圣诞节，然后再次去侦查，再次去直播对吧？然后嘞嗯又有新玩具，这次新玩具来谁担心啊？
谁担心来新玩具获得小主人新的宠爱呀？在这里啊。
巴斯光年比较担心，对吧？他现在是家里最受宠的玩具啊。然后这场戏有几个呼应啊，这场戏有几个呼应啊，首先是不是回到原点啊？
首尾呼应啊，我们说回到原点似而不同，这个呼应学会了没有啊？
同时还有个什么忽悠啊？
双男主最后要干什么？成为彼此来，我们看一下成为彼此巴斯光年成为胡弟。你看啊，他坐在床上，床上以前是胡弟坐的，巴斯光年坐在了床上，在这焦急的听着收音机。最后一个礼物是谁？我说他已经成为了胡弟，对不对？胡弟成为巴斯。
是哪一场？
看到了吧。
哭地说巴斯的口头禅。
因为他们俩在之前争吵过，谁的语言多，对吧？我的语言都是拉线，他的语言都是电子的。
呼弟说了巴斯的台词。
在这里表示，胡迪相信了巴斯的飞行梦，融入了巴斯的飞行梦，融入了巴斯的英雄梦。他之前说巴斯不切实际，什么宇宙，什么英雄，you are just a toy,对吧？。
这部电影本来原名叫you are toy，懂吗？这是胡地的台词，you are just toy.
但是他这里说我们可以飞向浩瀚的宇宙。
我们可以冲向无限，这30个节拍一出来。
故事的走线我们就非常清楚了。这故事主角主线目标是什么？一句话故事是什么？不就是一个本来在家里当老大最受宠的一个玩具。
来了的非常牛逼的巴斯光年以后。
决定夺回自己首席的地位嘛。
那么主题也非常清楚了。
显然是。
夺回自己的爱爱的主题，爱的主题是个范畴。那么这里。
首先一个主题，那就爱是责任呀。
你想要夺回同伴的爱，你得对同伴负责任吧。你不能对同伴撒谎吧，你要帮助大家吧。
你只要夺回主人的爱，你要对主人忠诚吧，对不对？
所以说爱是一种责任，甚至你可以引申出爱是一种付出。这样一个主题就非常清楚了。这个故事最大的一个特点是什么？同学我我我教你们学写这类故事，因为这类故事最大的特点是什么？因为这个故事最大的特点就是双男主的设定方式。我们说这种双男主的设定方式，当然有一组一次啊，湖底稍稍为主。
巴斯稍稍为次，那么我们就来看这个双男主的设定，非常典型的喜剧人物设定。你记一下啊，你们以后写双男主的时候啊，也可以这么设。我们说胡狸是什么类型的人设啊，是非常典型的既得利益者，当然了，他这个既得利益，人家又叠加了别的。
别的人设啊，但是他的大类属于既得利益者，他有些什么样的其他的人设呢？比如说他是个利己主义，然后他又是个现实主义者，对应巴斯光年的理想主义，他是个现实主义者，然后他又是个要面子的人。同时基于他们都是玩具。所以还给他了加了一个属于玩具特有的设定。
他是一个过时的老玩具是吧？提现木偶嘛，拉弦的对吧？人家八斯光年是装电的，而且从身份上也比人家老，他是个牛仔对吧？人家是个宇航员，我们说后面这些设定当然是一些细节补充，但是呼底的喜剧大类属于既得利益者，或者是那叫原住民之类，辅助词，这个词相对挺准的啊，补助一般搭配什么搭配闯入者，八斯光年是个闯入者。
我们再来看一下巴斯光年的人物设定，他是个理想主义者，英雄主义者二显摆。然后呢又是个新人类，他是个太空人嘛，讲的是最新的一些理念。这个呢是专门跟乎底形成对比的，他是个闯入者，同时他又是另外一种喜剧人物类型，他又是一个妄人狂妄的妄。
望人就是理想主义，英雄主义。望人形象塑造最好的是范德彪。但是。
范德彪在马大帅里是土著，不是超包makerr，赵本山反而是闯入者，是超包makerr。你能理解这个灵活运用吗？回想一下马大帅和范德彪的关系，再想一想，胡迪和巴斯光年的关系，都是一个原住民加一个闯入者，然后呢都有一个妄人，只不过在。
马大帅里枉然是。
土猪在玩具总动员里面。
望人是闯入者，但是闯入者就又一定是trolemakerr。所以说这个原住民要去解决问题，这也是为什么马大赛能拍成剧是吧？等于是外来的这个人必然不适应环境，然后制造各种麻烦。但是解决这个问题的人呢又是个250，又是个理想主义者，英雄主义者，所以他他又解决不了，导致。
导致马大帅就拍成了一个剧，姐夫和小舅子无限拉扯。然后在电影里面，我们说闯入者是个妄人，他有点彪。然后呢，我们的忽底我们的缺陷是有点小肚鸡肠，有点利己主义，但是是清醒的，所以能解决问题，这也就是电影组合，能不能理解我让你们拓展阅读马大帅的原因啊。
我多说一句啊，同学们，你如果能触类旁通的话，你想一想为什么当时。
触不可及。这部电影出来的时候。
我们觉得他很工整，但是又很震撼。你说是为什么？
就触不可及这种故事啊，我从我们编剧的角度，我们乍一看，觉得太工整了呀。一个全身瘫痪，一个活蹦乱跳，一个在穷的破产，一个富可敌国，跟雕科书似的，怎么还挺好看的呢？是因为他全部反套路，原住民有问题，绑入者帮原住民解决问题。
而且闯入者还是个旺人望人。
就是负负得政，本来闯入者是不能解决原住民的问题的，望人也不适合去解决别人的问题。但是一个闯入的妄人竟然可以解决他的问题。负负得正。那我们来想一下，这种设定方式，两个人如此之互补，那必然要成长，走到对面。记住啊，两个人成为彼此啊，只是一个。
概念化的成为彼此，并不能真正的成为对方呀。真正的成为对方呢他的缺陷我也我也继承了呗，互相取得获取对方的优点。，那么在获取对方这在成为彼此之前，我们先得弥补自己的缺陷嘛。来我们这部戏，我们看一下两个人物的成长。
两个人物的成。
呼地学会了什么？呼地学会了。
奉献你看巴斯最强调的是成为英雄呀。
那么胡狸缺的不就是这个吗？狐狸缺的就是对别人的责任，对别人的爱呀，对吧？所以呼弟学会了爱与奉献，学会了责任感。8四光年前还是学会了脚踏实地呀，理性面对自己。同学们在日常生活中，其实我们大部分人是忽弟。
我们希望得到别人的爱，但是不想付出自己的爱，然后立己主义，小肚鸡肠。我们大部分人是糊弟。但是看戏的时候呢，大部分人愿意共情自己是巴斯光年，认为自己本来是个英雄，但是呢不得不面对现实，承认自己是个普通人。我刚才说。
关于巴斯光年的三次起飞，我想讲一讲，为什么很重要？同学们，我最早学戏的时候啊，曾经有一位老先生，这位老先生对我说的这句话，我从来没有在任何教材上再看到过。所以我偷偷告诉你，他跟我说，在任何故事里都想办法。
让主角飞如果是非常现实主义的题材，那就让主角自由坠落，或者那叫灵魂一跃啊，自由坠落人啊飞翔的梦想是所有人刻在记忆里边。所以当时那个老编剧跟我说，写戏啊，你反正写电视剧那么长。
哪怕跳楼呢也来一次自由落辑，或者飞一次。我们记着这句话，我们生活当中灵活运用好不好？这部戏我们说还有几个特点啊，其实刚才在捋信息拍的时候已经说过了，就是。
这部戏的。
这个这个叫配角团伙伴设定分成了两波啊，略微有点浪费篇幅啊。这个土豆先生弹簧狗牧羊女啊发挥的作用太少了。但是当然了，他们被困在对方家里了，该说不说啊，总玩具总动员一的时候确实这个地方没有照顾到。但是反派的设定实际是不错的。
把反派设定成小朋友。同学们在95年。
把反派制定成小朋友。在95年。
还是需要一些勇气的，还是需要创作者有一些魄力的。同学们这个还是不错的啊，再说一个点，关于95年，有很多人认为这部电影，乔布斯作为制品肯定有他不一样的用意。有很多人说他在他在描绘冷战，当时反正冷战结束了嘛，之雷已经解体了。他说牛仔代表美国宇航员代表。
俄罗斯讲的是两个超级大国之间应该和平共处，互相帮助。很多同学说这部电影有政治隐喻，你们认为这部电影有政治隐喻吗？我说一下我的观点啊，我认为完全没有政治隐喻。首先，牛仔代表的是老一代的美国人。巴斯光年代表的是新一代的美国人。
re go for you对，代表的是科技的迭代，是代表他们自己的迭代。然后美国人拍个电影怎么可能还隐喻你前苏脸呢？你想多了，另外最直接的证据是这个玩具，为什么叫巴斯光年，巴斯是谁呀？
同学们，你们知道阿姆斯特朗吗？第一个在月球上踩下脚印的人，巴斯就是第二个巴斯跟在阿姆斯特朗后面出去的。阿姆斯特朗走出去以后，巴斯也跳下去了。
所以这个玩具是以他的命名是以他的名字命名的。而且这个巴斯曾经也给自己封了一个第一。因为这个巴斯这个人嗯后来一直被人调侃了一辈子啊，说他跟阿姆斯特朗一块登月，但是全世界只记只知道阿姆斯特朗，他曾经有个很著名的一个玩笑。他说阿姆斯特朗是第一个登上月球的人。
他说我是人类历史上第一个登上地球的人，因为下来的时候是他先出来的。我们说双男主系或者叫双主角戏。我们很多时候要解决两个人的感情下来。比如说这个相遇。我曾经说过，要有一个激烈的相遇，遗式化的相遇，不一样的相遇，埋下伏笔的相遇，注定两个人要在一起互相帮助的相遇。
今天是不是就学了一种非常特别的相遇，或者是说叫非常好用。在你未来创作生涯当中，你可以用个三五回的这种相遇，也就是两个主角有一个不小心或者也不叫不小心，我开始确实想坑他，但是没想到把他害的这么惨。
先天带着愧疚，先天带着我要帮他，先天带着我要赎罪，我要补偿他。我们说这种情况，比较激烈的人物关系开场用在爱情里面，那可是太好人了。那么这种写法我们要注意。
完以后啊，我们得过度补偿。
我们不能说解释一下就完了，在日常生活中可以，我们必须让这个角色过度补偿，必须补偿到观众觉得巴斯光年又欠胡迪的呢。
这个是要注意的，不是说我把水端平了就完事儿了。然后再往回扯。那么我们今天就学会了一类故事的写法。首先说男种，其次，既得利益或者是些土著和闯入者中配搭，然后呢，里面可以存在一个妄人，妄人可以是土著，也可以是闯入者。在这部戏里面。
然后故事的起因是什么呢？我要跟他夺权争宠，但是我不小心把他给坑了，所以我要赎罪，再去把他找回来，再去把他救回来，获得他和观众的原谅。这类故事在我们今后的创作生涯中，我可以向你保证，你会经常用到。好吧，从今天开始，遇到双主角。
不管双男主还是双女主还是一男一女，不慌了，行吗？至少我们学会了一个土著，一个闯入，一个旺人，一个现实主义。现实主义那个你就可以设了有点小猪鸡肠，有点斤斤计较，但是你一定要给他搭配一个利己主义现实主义者。你们去看一下好汉两个伴，一个枉人，一个利即主义者，尤先是一个抠门的人。今天。
我们学到的就是以后再写双子座不慌轻松应对，而且知道设定完了之后后面的剧情。
基本够呛。好吧，有个同学说写电视剧的时候，主角设置缺陷，容易让观众在前几集戏剧。你还是那句话，缺陷不一定会让观众弃剧呀，缺陷反而是让观众觉得这个角色活灵活现的，不用隐藏缺陷。你还你如果觉得前几集应该隐藏缺陷，反而是你这个缺陷肯定不好，你就突然前面都很好，自己告诉大他以前强调。
是捞不回来了呀，对吧？这肯定是你缺陷是的不好呀，缺陷怎么换干嘛要隐藏要主角尽量完美呢？完美他妈谁还看呀，完美反而不好看，反而没共情，反而观众不喜欢大家不要把缺陷就理解成这个人脏了，或者是这人犯罪了，或者这人是个十6不赦的坏蛋，别这么想呀，先这样了，拜拜。
。